[Conan] While I was in Haiti I visited the
Ecole Nouvelle Zoranje.
A school that serves some
of the poorest children
living in Port-au-Prince.
(children chanting)
(group chanting)
(chanting)
I hear a lot of giggling,
is that a good sign?
Am I pretty? Est-ce belle?
[Children] Oui!
Ah, Est-ce belle, eh?
(children chattering)
(laughter)
(children singing)
I'm okay!
(children screeching)
I'm good again!
[Children] Oui!
Bonjou!
[Children] Bonjou!
Hi, don't mind me.
I'm just gonna join you,
just don't mind me,
I'm good.
Hi, hi,
I'm gonna need a little more room up here.
Kinda sticks up a little bit.
Hi.
Eyes forward, up there.
(children read in unison)
Can I try?
(clears throat)
Noo say
I seeyen
no kway
non te noo,
noo...
Noo Sa
koo nu ya see yo
respecte Nooooo!
(cheering)
(chanting)
(drumming)
(children laughing)
Yah!
Yes!
She gets me!
(audience clapping)
Finally someone gets me.
(children singing)
(children laughing)
Oh thank you!
Merci!
(classroom chanting)
(drumming)
Finit!
Yeah!
As I was leaving the school,
I was suddenly surrounded by
my very curious classmates.
Who's the--What did she ask?
[Interpreter] She ask you who is the
President of the United States.
Who is the President of
the United States now?
[Interpreter] Yes.
Oh. Okay. This is awkward.
His name is Donald Trump.
Who's heard of Donald Trump?
Can you translate Donald
Trump was on television,
(interpreter translates)
and then a bunch of grown ups got drunk
and they made him president.
(audience laughter)
And this man, this crazy
man with crazy hair,
he became president, that's
why I'm moving to Haiti.
My wife says I'm crazy.
Do you think that she's right?
(interpreter translates)
[Children] No!
You don't think I'm crazy?
(interpreter translates)
[Children] No!
Ask the president the same question--
(laughter)
[Interpreter] He ask what
did Trump say about Haiti.
Uh Trump, what did Trump say about Haiti?
Yeah
Oh boy, I'm not gonna--
I'm not gonna--
What'd you say?
What'd she say?
She said don't pay him no mind.
(laughter)
She's like don't worry about him--
What do you know that we don't know?
These kids are fascinated
with my freckles, aren't they.
Ask them if they've seen freckles before.
(interpreter translates)
[Children] No.
Do you like them?
[Children] Oui.
The freckles don't come off by the way.
They stay on.
Maybe Americans need to
help Haiti put things back,
is that right?
I'm not gonna take your stuff.
(interpeter laughs)
Can I say something?
I think you have--this
is your next president.
She is the president, she is
the next president of Haiti,
right here.
No, she is not wrong that,
that America in history
has not been good to Haiti.
But there's still a chance
for America to be better
to Haiti, I think.
There's still a chance.
Does that sound good to you?
[Interpreter] Now you're talkin, bro.
Oh good, so you agree with me.
We'll make a deal on that?
A deal? Okay?
[Interpreter] She wants to be the
President of the United States of America.
Alright, ask her if she
can do it starting now.
(interpreter translates)
Yes! Just ask her if she tweets.
Does she tweet?
(interpreter translates)
Perfect. Perfect.
She doesn't do tweets.
Perfect.